[Applause]
these protesters are yelling it reporter
Tim Poole I'm not gonna let them bully
me out of reporting on what they're
doing
pools part of what some call the new
media reporters who work for themselves
and often cover things the mainstream
media miss the news you're getting comes
straight from me and straight from the
source
on the ground that brings them viewers
more than a million people subscribe to
pools online channel here he's
videotaping and Tifa protesters who try
to stop him pool the anti-shah
de-escalation team actually called it
said don't touch him and so they
actually made sure people didn't touch
me which is good and TFI has a
de-escalation team yeah they have people
who try and make sure nobody you know no
one from their side starts it because
the cameras are rolling you call
yourself a person of the left and you
worked advice yeah but now you're mostly
criticizing the left this really strange
faction of people on the left that are
saying ridiculous things that make no
sense they're hurting the left and
they're helping Donald Trump Trump gets
voters who watched those protests yep do
look at this protest in Portland a
Bernie Sanders supporter shut up with an
American flag to protest against the
fascists and so what did anti-fur do
cracked him over the head with a club
put him in the hospital with a
concussion
[Music]
pull won fans with his coverage of the
Covington school conflict all of these
big news outlets even the Washington
Post CNN they immediately made the
assumption he must be a racist sneering
at this Native American man I didn't
make that assumption I just see a guy
banging a drum and a kid with a weird
look on his face so I looked at some
other videos and posted his own video
explanation
the initial narrative that we heard from
the activists was that this kid got in
this man's face you have just seen right
now it's actually the other way around
no one else watched the video how could
that be no one watched the longer video
nope here's what happens one one
left-wing journalist says look at this
racist his buddy season says wow look at
this racist and then it's a big ol
circular game a telephone where no one
actually does any fact-checking and then
New York Times Washington Post CNN all
publish the same fake story pool and
reasons Robbie suave told the true story
that's a complete complete misreading of
the situation that's exactly backward
pool doesn't have a college degree or
even a high school degree I like it that
you're a high school dropout yeah me too
instead of going to college and taking
on debt cool just started videotaping
what interested him I went to Occupy
Wall Street has begun
at 13th Street and Broadway for those
just tuning in he covered the riots in
Ferguson Missouri
that's the first time I've been fired at
you're an action junkie you know it's
not so much the action but kind of you
know definitely an adrenaline junkie
I've been skateboarding my whole life
but it was more so I want to know why
things are happening some people don't
trust the media I don't know who to
believe why don't I just go there I can
see for myself and then it turns out
there's one good way to fund that tell
people what you saw he founds his videos
with advertising and contributions from
viewers his most popular YouTube video
was when he went to Sweden to look at
so-called no-go zones Trumpets said
their areas where you can't go no-go
zones your video said what that it was
nuanced you got lots of views with
nuance yeah Poole interviewed lots of
people and they were looting the stores
here and one viewers by concluding they
certainly have their problems but you
know one side will have you believe it's
the end of the world and other will have
you believe nothing's happening at all
Poole is now a zealot for free speech
when I was growing up it was the
religious conservatives that had the
moral panic about music and swear words
but today the moral panic is coming from
the left what happened to the left at
Berkeley holding up signs saying free
speech today the left shows up with
torches and burns free speech signs
that's not the left and so you know it
is lift but it's like the old glow they
want everyone to believe that someone
like me who was a supporter of Bernie
Sanders is a conservative that way
actual conservatives look insane Poole
is one of many new media people who are
changing how reporting is done
independent uncensored I don't agree
with everything they say but I'm sure
glad they're out there they give us more
choice